hi welcome okay so the background of
this talk is which might be interesting
to you because we are in Norway is um
because I worked for the last three or
four years with the Norwegian government
especially the healthcare sector because
they were basically redoing their
infrastructure from you know more
traditional style of security to an
OAuth and OpenID connect based system so
you know part of that ongoing project
which is a huge bonus you can imagine is
you know raising security awareness by
for all the people that work or you know
that touch these systems so one
deliverable if you like was to create a
training course that you know talks
about OpenID connect and all security
best practices and this is think of it
as like the 60 minute version of that so
in some way this talk is sponsored by
Norway okay oh yeah I have to warn you
though yeah when you start looking into
these things you have to deal with
documents that look like this okay so
that's a Korea font you know do you know
the fun stops here right it's all
serious now luckily they have a PDF
document for you a PDF version right so
if that's too harsh for your eyes you
can try this one oh no you can't yeah
yeah the other thing you have probably
you know have to get used to is things
like this ASCII art okay so I really
hope someone has a tool for that they
don't have to you know like space space
space you know and you know the reason
why these documents look like this is
basically goes all the way back because
it's the ietf right I mean they they
made the internet right so it had to
work on the very first browser that was
ever in existence do you remember what
it was the protocol links looks like
this right so when I
[Music]
what's the key combination here ctrl-g
no anyways if you would open up that
same URL it would look exactly like what
you just seen in Chrome
okay and that's 30 years of backwards
compatibility and they even had dock
mode right by then so you know okay good
my name is Dominick and you know I'm I'm
working in that space for a very long
time I am the author of one of the the
oh bloody connect certified open ID and
oh of implementation called identity
server for yeah so I'm pretty much you
know half the luxury and some people are
not clear what luxury means in this case
of working full time with these things
okay I uploaded the slide deck to here
to speak attack.com slashed his
privilege so if you want to have that
slide that you can just download it
right now if you want or you know after
the talk the rough plan is this give you
a little bit of overview of what
security guidance is out there today you
know help you with categorizing what
multiplies to you what does not apply to
you where does it fit in into the big
picture so to speak and then we had and
then I picked out a couple of
interesting use cases here are some more
common some maybe uncommon ones here
they are by far not all of the use cases
that are described in this document so
you you know that the call to action
would be afterwards start downloading
these things they're tiny they're just
text files no berries yeah and after
that I want to talk a bit a little bit
about what's happening with or wolf in
the future because there is some
interesting thing going on right now
which will impact all of us okay
this give me some context first okay so
the very first web-based protocol you
know you would say it was sam'l to pee
yeah it was it basically invented the
pattern that we all use today which is
goes to some external provider get a
postback with some stuff okay and that's
basically how do you all work openly
Connect OFWs Federation similar and so
on so they basically invented this
pattern if you like yeah
sam'l sam'l was an authentication
protocol it didn't solve the API access
problem because what guess what there
were no API in 2005 right so Olaf was
invented to in addition solve the
token-based API access problem but again
a wolf 1.0 is pretty old it used some
old technology was hard to use actually
lots of crypto involved so in 2012 they
came up with o of 2.0 and they made a
simplified version of OAuth not
everybody was happy with that to be
honest because the crypto was gone to
make it easier but security you could
say was lower than in or of 1.0 if
you've you know Google for whatever what
they do the original spec offer of the
OAuth spec he left because it was so
angry with the IETF that they watered
down his little protocol that he created
in the first place and I think he had
good good points here umm one of the
results of him being so angry is he
demanded
you must publish a threat model with
that right so you know certain things
you can do in awe of are insecure and
the spec doesn't give you any guidance
if you should do it like this or like
that or what's the right way of doing it
right so they created this threat model
and security considerations document but
imagine this was written at the same
time respect was written so all that's
in there is what they knew by the time
right and again since it Olaf wasn't it
not really applied to practical
scenarios by the time they also couldn't
give you like really actionable guidance
they could just point out that's a
potential problem that's a potential
problem and that's a potential problem
yeah but not saying telling you how to
fix it exactly okay so you know that
that thing was out there for a while and
then new specs got created yeah and just
that's just a fraction of the specs
actually someone counted all the pages
of these specs recently and he said it's
doubled the size of war and peace which
i think is a pretty big book right so
you decide what's more exciting to read
but the point was this and many people
said like okay the phret model is old
the phret model doesn't give us any
guide
can be produced new documents on top
that actually gives a developer real
guidance in what to do okay and not just
what to potentially do ma'am and that's
what they call the security or that the
best current practices PC piece yeah
there is a reason why the word current
is in there right because the older they
get the less current they are so they
try to capture what happens at this
point in time and give it you know give
you concrete guidance on how to
implement things the first of them was
for native applications there are mobile
apps ma'am because there was a big thing
people started using OAuth for dead how
do you do it right as we speak there are
two other very important PC piece being
worked on one is called the O of to o
security topics PCP which you can think
of is an update to the threat model okay
so what have we learned in the last
eight years so to speak how OAuth was
applied and what from our point of view
are now the current mitigation
techniques what are the attacks and so
on and a very very important other one
is the OAuth for Prowse abased
apps PCP right because as we all know
browsers are the hardest thing to secure
you need a lot of guidance there okay so
basically the talk is about the red
things here ma'am so if you want to put
that into perspective the threat model
was the mother of all PC piece if you
like then this one is a very general one
which talks about OAuth in general and
then on top you see the two which which
talk about very specific application
scenarios and just recently two new ones
popped up which are not essential for
our discussion but they belong to that
bigger picture one is how to use JSON
web tokens securely in OAuth and then
how to use JSON web token specifically
for access tokens because both never
specified at open format yeah cool so
that's how a typical warf based system
looks like or OpenID Connect based
system looks like we have front ends we
have back ends we have seconds for back
ends right we have users we have clients
we have authentication we have Apix
and typically a thing called the
security token service is what
coordinates all these things like a
traffic cop if you like that hands out
the tokens makes the access checks and
and much more okay to simplify that what
oh of really how oh of really works is
like this you have something called a
resource owner which is in my world a
user which it's a better word for it you
have a client which is an application
you have a resource server which is an
API typically and you have this thing
called the authorization server yeah and
regardless how you use o of it will
always work like this you first go to
the authorization server you get a token
and then you use that token to access
the resource there are a couple of
flavors but in essence that's how it
works now the very first thing to think
about is when you're building such a
system who are my attackers right so if
you want to secure the system you need
to understand who is it who is attacking
them so and by the way I use the
cheesiest symbol for an attacker that I
could find on the Internet
yeah forgive me I guess but the very
first type of attack you have to think
about is what if my infrastructure is
compromised ok so somebody can read or
modify traffic or maybe can even you
know tamper with my DNS infrastructure
yeah so one thing to think about is okay
why can't why can they read and modify
traffic because are you using TLS TLS it
is mandatory for a wharf ok um so you
should never ever do anything I mean
anything yeah without TLS yeah but if
your infrastructure is still compromised
and they can still read and modify
traffic even over TLS you have a huge
problem that we can solve as
implementers that's a whole nother world
of you know problems so we have to rely
on that being intact ok um the next type
of attack would be the compromise of an
endpoint itself yeah what what if the
client is compromised what if the
authorization server is compromised what
if the resource service
promisor again from an OAuth implementer
point of view or from a protocol point
of view there's not lot not a lot you
can do about this you have to find out
why are these things compromised now you
know you can't trust them
this will be an insecure system let's
move on to something else
which I think in my mind is the
battleground of the future yeah they
don't have to moderate they don't have
to compromise anything they add stuff to
your system for example a rogue
authorization server or a rogue client
or a rogue resource server and maybe
they even managed to register their
rogue resource server with the
legitimate authorization server or they
trick the legitimate client into using
the rogue authorization server and you
can imagine any permutation of that
being very problematic okay that's what
we see today for very targeted attacks
here where someone specifically targets
a certain application or company right
where maybe the implementation is really
good but this might give you a lot of
avenue for confusion and unforeseen
vulnerabilities in your system okay I'm
going to show you an example of that
later sadly to be honest the 90% types
of warf attacks we see our
implementation flaws right somebody has
written an O of Server somebody has
written an OAuth client they didn't
follow the best practices and stuff goes
wrong so for example the idea is that an
attacker can read but not modify the
contents of the authorization request
and the response okay this doesn't that
does not necessarily need network access
this might only mean right maybe your
application has a bug and you have an
open redirector in there maybe somebody
can redirect the intercept intercept you
with a redirection on a mobile device
maybe you are leaking Network packages
like in log files or in proxies or in
the browser history you know all of
these things here these are by far the
mod of the most common attacks we see
and the good news is they can all be
fixed by writing the right code okay
good
so the elephant in the room that's what
the whole oh of security discussion cut
cut you know started again after being
torment for a while was this guy Osmond
garage dead well respected colleague of
mine who wrote his blog post you should
not use the oh of implicit grunt and you
might know that right the over fambissig
grant was by the time D recommendation
for implementing browser-based
applications here so he wrote this blog
post and he used these words here this
might for example result in an attack
attacker accessing your health records
or initiating a payment from your bank
account and you could only imagine what
happened the next day I got emails from
customers all over the place saying hey
have you read this there's a new
vulnerability you know of and I said no
that's not true it's not a new
vulnerability it's a known weakness of
this specific flow that you can mitigate
if you're writing the right code the
problem is many companies don't write
the right code and it's and you know
like the real problem with implicit flow
is it's error-prone ok so just to recap
that what's what's the implicit flow the
inviscid flow was invented to give
JavaScript based applications an easy
way to request tokens from an
authorization server given that
cross-origin Ajax calls it not exist by
the time okay 2012 there was no cross
air cross origin Ajax calls so they had
to find something that is purely working
on URLs right so you asked this guy for
a token you get back their token on the
URL okay and that is error-prone because
as I said this URL ends I've been locked
files this URL ends up in the browser
history and browser behavior has changed
as how a hash fragment has been treated
for example and imagine referrer headers
and you know it is troublesome ok it's
not that a new vulnerability has been
discovered this was always the case from
day one and to be honest the threat
model pointed this out explicitly but I
guess no one read the phret model yeah
so long story short now today we have
course right
the cross-origin resource sharing which
allows us to do cross-origin HX course
which means we can use a different flow
that you know uses HX which does not
have to use URLs so implicit flow will
be deprecated okay no more implicit flow
it's not needed anymore right it's it's
been cleared out of a need but it's not
needed anymore and as I said it's not
inherently insecure it's just error
prone to implement so we want to get rid
of this okay that's action item number
one um while we are at deprecating stuff
no more password current ok the past but
current was this very very old flow in a
wharf where you collect the credentials
of the user in the front end and then
send them to a token service and you get
back a token this is bad practice all
over okay you are encouraging users to
type in passwords in different places
research has shown the more often a user
types in the password they're more prone
they are too phishing attacks for
example and you know this is not
compatible with any of the of the modern
authentication techniques like Fido to
of a Federation and so on it's still
widely in use mostly for legacy or for
other reasons that to be the only
product owners know again this is going
to be deprecated that's action item
number two don't use it so which is
quite nice that's good you know we
improve by reduction so to speak yeah
when you know I'm doing is oh of
training for a long time and that was
kind of like that netted the decision
matrix at the end of a training right if
you're doing this use this flow if
you're doing this use this or that or
that if you're doing this use this or
this or that yeah
now I have crossed out the deprecated
ones and it turns out as I'll show you
in a second when you basically you know
apply apply common sense here all we
need is two flows
right because all we have are two
fundamental types of applications one
our machine to machine there is the
OAuth client good ends will flow for
that and the other type is interactive
applications where a human being is
using it and for all the other cases we
now use the good-old actually the mother
of all flows in our wolf called the
authorization code flow the mother of
all flows has a problem that's what
that's what we're going to fix with the
thing called pixie I'm going to show you
in a second what that is
but ultimately speaking you only you
only need to choose between one of the
two your developers only need to learn
these two right and your architect only
need to understand these two that's it
and that's much better than a year ago
good so let's start with machine to
machine communication as I said the way
this works is the client goes to the
authorization server of indicator of the
authorization server asks for an access
token for certain resources gets back an
access token if if he's allowed to do
that uses the access token that's it
okay so what what is there to harden
good question the first thing I guess
that still is around a lot is how do the
clients authenticate with the server
obviously the easiest way it seems at
least our shared secrets right so you
have a secret here you have a secret
there if someone can prove that secret
is known then you know he's offended
shared secrets are not really secrets
because they are shared um so don't try
to avoid them okay I mean they are the
easiest thing today but in practice when
you implement this configuration
management is really hard right where do
you store them where do you store them
not in clear-text
how do you store them that they don't
leak to your to your version control
system or you know other things it's um
you know if you use them yeah use high
entropy secrets like weeds or random
numbers or something like this don't
even try to you know it's a password but
it's a password for machines they don't
need to be memorable okay they can be
really long and really hard yeah if you
are storing them store them on
reversibly right if somebody compromises
the database of the authorization server
they shouldn't be presented with a menu
of Secrets yeah what they should see is
it's hashes of Secrets
now since the secrets have high entropy
so you don't need to apply any key bite
stretching for example you know it's a
good hashtag ooh it that's good if you
can move away from shared secrets use a
symmetric keys the nice thing about a
symmetric keys is a the server does not
need to store any secret at all because
all they store is the public key right
and nothing else they never go over the
wire so you can't intercept them on the
network because you're all you're
sending is a signature that it has been
done with the secret and not a secret
itself okay and it has the nice side
effect that it gives us more features
which is called sender constraining and
the most important one of the most
common ways to do a symmetric keys these
days is either signing basically
creating a chase on their token signing
it with the secret and using that as a
client secret or you're using the
transport like mutual TLS for example so
that the transport layer protocol will
take care of these things okay
the nice thing about TLS is that it
gives us what we call sender constraint
tokens or proof of possession tokens
meaning if the client asked for a token
over a mutual TLS connection once the
TLS certain certificate valid ated we
can basically put the hash of that
certificate into the access token itself
why are the CNS claimed it stands for
confirmation and then the client used
the same client certificate to talk to
the api's the API receives the access
token it gets the the thumbprint of the
client certificate can compare that
thumbprint with the thumbprint in the
access token and then you know this was
really the client that asked for the
token in the first place if an attacker
steals their token they can't use it
because they don't have the private key
okay that is I think for 20/20 we should
make sure that we are using this
technique because it's it's easy to use
and it's so much more secure okay
speaking of chasing up tokens as I said
chasing up tokens have never been
specified for Olaf yeah it was just a
thing that happened
because they were around they are easy
to use they are widely deployed there
are so many client libraries that can
deal with them so people fought like hey
Jason Depp tokens yeah let's use them
for everything yeah they seem to be a
nice way to protect a chase and object
and they are um so X chasing Depp tokens
I used today for identity tokens and OPA
D Kinect for access tokens in a wharf a
lot for lockout tokens for single sign
out security events is another aspect
that users chase in depth tokens does
the funny thing is once you start using
them all over they become a bit
complicated because you can't really
distinguish between them anymore they
all look the same right they have a
header and they have a payload and they
have a signature okay so give you one
example here's the spec of the lookout
token validation yeah so they say like
you know yeah validate a signature
that's fine
validate that it contains a sub claim
and so and so on that's fine
and then it says something like this
verify the token does not contain a
nonce
and why is that well because if it would
contain a nonce it could be actually an
identity token that someone tries to
smuggle into your system saying hey
here's a log out token okay because you
know it's hard to distinguish between
them so a really very small thing that
you should start using is called typed
chasing their tokens and the idea is
that here you see that that that type
header that always said short but now
what you should do is you should
introduce the basically encode the
purpose of the chase in depth token into
the chase in depth token itself so
currently the the o of spec for JSON web
token says use the value 80 plus JWT
okay that tells the system this is a
JSON web token but it is also an access
token because it has this well-known
string in the type header okay and what
you should do is if you come up with
your own chasing web tokens in invent a
name for them right so that someone
can't confuse one type with the other
I'm working on this thing called
identity server we start doing that now
since I think six months all of our
access tokens look like this
okay just to make sure that when you are
validating them you can make sure it's
actually an access token it's not a
logout token it's not a security and
it's not an ID token or whatever other
things you come up with okay so that's
all something you should do good let's
switch gears to interactive applications
and they are browser-based right the
browser is very powerful right it can
show UI it you know it can follow
redirects and so on but the browser is
also the most problematic part of the
system because where it can show UI it
can follow redirects right maybe to the
wrong place yeah so be careful with that
but how does that flow work well it's
super simple right you have two channels
one it's called the front channel one is
called the back channel you first do the
authorized request you get presented
with some UI on the server the server
replies with a so-called authorization
code and then the authorization code
gets on a back channel communication
redeemed and turned into access tokens
right to redeem that access token the
client has to authenticate with the
authorization server and that makes the
authorization code quite nice right
because if an attacker sits in your
browser or on your network because you
know you're at the airport and the Wi-Fi
called free Wi-Fi was very attractive to
you yeah who knows who who runs that
Network right if they would steal that
authorization code from you they cannot
redeem it without knowing the secret
okay only the client knows the secret
and that's the only party that can turn
this code into um a token okay job done
right we're good yeah that is where most
things go wrong okay and I'm just
picking out this one because it's the
most popular because you know on this
leg here when the server response back
to the client application that is a very
sensitive operation right because that's
where you where you deliver the data and
that's called the redirect URI and the
spec says the redirect URI must be pre
registered with the client and there
must be an exact string matching between
the redirect URI that was pre registered
and the one
that's being used at runtime that's what
the spec says but that's not what people
do apparently yeah so for example this
year I've seen this in the wild
yeah let's allow it on our side but any
sub-domain okay so that actually
happened to Electronic Arts last year
there wasn't a tech called sub domain
takeover so basically that the short
story is somebody created a website on
Asha it was called something-something
Asha websites dotnet and they
implemented the EEA billing system on
this at some point they were ready so
they put a DNS entry into the EA dot-com
domain billing dot EA dot-com points now
to ECHA websites
fine right at some point they moved the
billing system to another domain
no no one needed it as a website anymore
they shut it down but no one took away
the DNS entry so now all an attacker
needs to do is scan your DNS say hey you
have this thing pointing to Asia but on
Azure there's nothing so let's just
register the HR website again with the
same name and now suddenly you can run
code under the EA domain right billing
dot EA tour comments now my server
because your DNS root routes me there
okay so yeah very dangerous um this one
here I have seen in the wild as well
mysite.com slash star any URL will do on
that site what they all have in common
is you are you are extending the attack
surface of the redirect there's a
callback URL if you like yeah on that
callback URL sensitive stuff is being
executed you want to tie that down to a
single place where your code is running
nothing else would run there no and no
Google Analytics I've seen that too no
ad banners I've seen that too only the
code dealing with the callback should
run on that specific URL and nothing
else if you do a star there true you can
choose whatever you want right that is
exactly what happened to Facebook by the
way yeah so Facebook allowed
facebook.com slash star is the callback
URL so someone was pretty clever and he
found out well
let's handcraft a URL that says you know
facebook.com slash my Facebook page and
send out these links right people
clicked on the links they came to
Facebook they locked on to Facebook they
ended up they ended up ultimately on his
Facebook page
okay that's annoying but it's that
dangerous yes it is because what he did
on his Facebook page he posted a picture
that came from a server that he controls
okay so now what is the browser doing he
loads the page he loads that evil calm
image PNG what does the browser put on
the referer header the code right that's
how he basically leaked the Facebook
authorization code to his log files now
so now you might think yeah but what's
the problem I need a client secret for
that right
that's what I just said yeah maybe not
there's another interesting attack
called authorization code injection
the idea is you steal an authorization
code somehow okay why are one of the
attacks open redirect a leakage whatever
I have stolen your authorization code
okay so now I just go to the legitimate
application start your authentication
process and then I handcraft a URL to
the callback endpoint that has the
stolen code right so now what will the
client application do they will take the
code and happily turn it into access
tokens because they have the secret and
I am now locked in as my victim to the
application right so even if code
requires a secret at least for
confidential clients there is still an
attack vector here if you can if you can
steal a code somehow if it got leaked
somehow okay so before code is the most
secure mechanism we turns out it's not
well but we can make it secure with
something on top which is called proof
key for code exchange or pixie as the
cool kids say yeah pixie is a very
simple extension to the authorization
flow and the idea is this before the
client makes the redirect to the token
servers
he comes up with a random number okay
just some random number and then he
hashes that random number and the random
number is called a code verifier and
hash of the random number is called a
code challenge okay so now when we do
the authorized request we in addition
send the hashed version of our secret to
the server right we we don't want to
send that a clear text version of it
because you know the browser is
considered insecure so now the server
stores dead code challenge and comes
back with the code right and now on the
back-channel communication the client
sends the clear text version of that
secret code verifier so now the server
has to clear text version he has the
hashed version so he can hash the clear
text version and if they match you can
prove that you are the Clyde the same
client on the front channel as you are
on the back channel okay now if that if
somebody somebody comes with a stolen
code this stolen code was requested
using a different code verifier than the
one that you can use because you don't
know the secret of the client yeah it's
just in memory so this wall will not
work anymore okay so long story short I
said earlier use authorization code flow
for all of your applications but only if
you use pixie on top of it okay
so code plus pixie is the requirement
and yeah if you're doing a speed on that
core for example starting with version
3.0 they always do pixie right it took a
bit of convincing them why why this is
useful but we managed that starting with
free free 0 they always send the code
challenge and in the code verifier
and then when you have a token service
like identity server you can basically
go to every client say require a pixie
require a pixie require a pixie and then
you shut down this problem ok cool let's
move on we have so much content as a
summary ok these are the most actionable
things always do exact matching of it
erects yeah don't do open redirect us
sounds easier than it is but you know do
it
[Music]
back pages should contain no third party
code only your code you see as P for
lockdown don't do inline Java you know
inline JavaScript always use pixie we
can skip the skate part that is also in
interesting but not as interesting
because pixie saves you from death also
that's a really nice easy one to do to
shut down refer ahead us yeah you can
you can have a refer a policy in your
browser to tell about the tone sent
refer I had us and you close that
potential problem as well
yeah good ha let's show you some more
advanced things ma'am which might make
your head hurt it it did dip with mine
the first time I saw it yeah it's called
a mix up attack and the mix of attack is
a more advanced scenario the idea is
that you're having a client that trusts
more than one authorization server right
think of a federation Gateway scenario
where you have you know Google login and
facebook login and decent isn't that so
yes you're already in that scenario
because your Federation gateway is a
client to more than one external
authentication system right so now I
told you that the sophisticated attacks
are the things where I can substitute
stuff and confuse the client application
somehow and that's one of them yeah it's
called the mix-up attack and it goes
like this the variant one by the way
makes the assumption that the attacker
can somehow modify the traffic between
the browser and the authorized you know
like the authorization request so to
speak ma'am but yeah we have to stss
yeah one is called the honest STS which
is the good one and one is called the
attacker STS which is the bad one so
imagine that the user clicks the honors
STS in the UI I want to login with this
guy or you know I get a token so he he
chooses that one the attacker can
on-the-fly change their two to the
attack is TS okay so now the client
things he wants to talk to the attacker
STS he stores the fact that this was the
selected STS he sends him free or two
back to go to the attacker STS and the
attacker
swaps it back out to the honest test yes
okay so now the browser goes to the
honest
yes the user authenticates you know does
his thing the authorized agent of a
sense to coat back the code travels up
to the client who is the client thinking
is the right sts to exchange the code
with the token the attacker is now
suddenly the attacker SDS has the
authorization code and the client ID and
the client secret right and all he has
to do now is just do a back-channel call
and redeem that with the honest sts to
make sense now you might say hard there
were a lot of assumptions here right and
there are okay but it is not made up
this has happened okay
there are assumptions here one is you
trust more than one STS you know someone
was able to smuggle in an attacker STS
into your system the idea attacker has
access to the network somehow okay that
might be far-fetched for some of you
there's a different variation which does
not require network access okay it works
a little bit different like this so the
idea is this the user selects the
attacker STS for some reason yeah maybe
you know maybe you have some sort of
self-service registration of your
customer STS or somebody posted in an
STS that is that looks very similar to
the one you really want to do right you
choose the wrong one that that's what
happens yeah you choose the wrong STS
then the client sends the the user agent
to the attacker STS yeah now what the
attack is the S is doing immediately is
he turns around and forwards that call
to the realist yes the honest STS you're
so you're seeing the right login page
everything he changes on the way he
changes the client ID he changes the
redirect URI and so on and so forth okay
so now the honest STS thinks he just got
a request from the client so he will
send the code back to the client
where will the the client sent the co to
now
to the attacker is this okay so yeah
that's a bit more advanced and I think
it requires a very specialized attack
for that but as I said this is not made
up ma'am
so how can we protect against this my
best answer I have is used a good
client-side framework okay if you have
written your own or openly connect
client library you know make sure you do
this though use authorization server
specific redirect you arise they
shouldn't share them right like one
endpoint that handles all the callbacks
that's a bad idea
store for each request the intended Stas
and then on the way back compare the
intended a s with the redirect URI that
belongs to the actual authorization
server okay the good news is if you do
if you're doing a spinet core they got
you covered
okay and to be honest this this
countermeasure was done by Microsoft
before the attack got published so it's
a bit like secure by accident I think
but it works so you know in in in a
spirit core every external provider must
Rama must have a unique name and must
use a unique callback URL okay so when
you initiate the challenge to the
external system what they can do is they
come up with a random number they call
that the correlation ID and they encrypt
and sign that random number and send it
on the state parameter to the
authorization server okay in the spec it
says that state parameter must be echoed
back unchanged to the client at the same
time what they do is they drop a cookie
that is called correlation thought
authorizations of a name dot correlation
I did a random thing they just made up
okay so now when the response comes back
from the authorization server
it's an AS specific callback URL right
and then they look at the state
parameter they unprotect that with their
you know key and so they decrypted and
valid validated signature so no no one
has changed it and then they get
relation ID out of that and they make
sure that a cookie exists with this name
correlation of relations of a name dot
correlation ID and only if that exists
you know that really the request and the
response they belong together
okay as I said if you're doing HP core
that's built in you don't need to worry
if you if you use something else you
need to check how how they are doing it
if you're all wrote something yourself
you should double check I guess yeah
okay whoo good so let's turn our
attention to a couple of different
things public clients okay so far we we
talked about what they call confidential
clients in OAuth which has a nice
security property they have client
secrets because they are they're
deployed to you know a trusted server or
something like this yeah
with public clients this assumption is
not true public lines are things running
in a browser
like JavaScript or a mobile app or a
desktop app they don't have secrets
because what's the point where would you
deploy that secret to right certainly
not in the source code am so different
rules apply here so in the Indy
confidential world we are used to having
basically a one-to-one mapping between
client and client ID right NBC one and
NBC two and my front end and my back end
and and so on with public lines that's
not true right because you're creating a
you know a mobile app my my cool client
you'd you deploy to the App Store five
million people download it five million
people will use the same client ID right
that's just the way it is ma'am so in
other words you can't authenticate the
client with public clients it's just not
possible so let's have a look first at
native clients for the very first
anti-pattern that gets pointed out by
the native clients PCP is don't use
native login dialogues right again I
said it earlier if you educate your
users to lot to type in the password in
many different places they are probably
more prone to phishing attacks so don't
do that this is using the deprecated
password flow in a wharf so that's
another reason why you shouldn't do that
yeah
but yeah there's really no point in
doing this as I said it's also not
compatible with things like two-factor
authentication and Fido and answer ones
the fourth yeah you wouldn't believe how
many discussions I had in my life with
product owners that insists on having a
native login dialog because well it's a
native app right we want to be in
control of every pixel on the screen the
other thing really that I don't like is
is that you are at the mercy of the
quality of the developer right you know
they should not store your personal
because they don't need it anymore
well hopeful hopefully they don't they
should store these tokens securely
hopefully they do right if you have time
make an experiment do a backup of your
iPhone for example right and the iPhone
backup has two parts the application
data and the keychain application data
is application data it's unprotected and
the keychain has all of your secrets now
take take a new phone and just restore
back the application data you should be
locked out everywhere try that if you
are not locked out everywhere some
developer stores your secrets in the
application data pocket where it's
completely unsecured yeah it's easy to
do so yes the easy answer is if you want
to do authentication in a native client
use code flow with pixie and open a
browser done okay you can reuse your
existing login page with all of your
security features logging auditing fraud
detection blah blah blah what have you
okay there's no point in in creating
another login page just because it must
be pixelated right open the browser go
to your login page use code flow with
pixie and you know there are different
types of browsers the preferred one is
the system browser okay so don't open
the web view for example like you know
like opening a little browser without
all of the browser things around use the
system browser you can inspect the URL
you can inspect the certificate if you
want to you can use password managers
and most importantly you can share the
cookie container with your system device
which might mean you already get single
sign-on because you are already logged
on to this
touken service in the browser right
basically what you're doing is you're
opening a tab of the system browser
inside your application and it behaves
exactly like this single sign-on less
password
typing better user experience less
phishing
okay you need to find a way how to get
the data back from the browser to your
app again there are a couple of options
here the most secure one is what they
call claimed HTTP URI HTTP URI I should
say and the idea is this right and you
can register so you've probably seen
that right when when you when you click
on a link to Google Maps and you have
Google that the Google Maps app
installed on your phone and they don't
open the browser they open the app right
or Amazon for example so the way this
works is that on that URL that you're
clicking there's a little XML file which
is signed by an apple developer
certificate that says hey if this app is
installed on the phone don't open the
browser open the app right and that's
how you can get back data to locally
installed apps from the web pack and
that's the best way to do it there are
other options here the spec has more
detail but my money is on the last one
cool now let's all get a little
pessimistic let's look what's pass um
you know I did the workshop the last two
days you asked them how many of you do
spas almost everybody have raises his
hand right I mean that's what people do
but it's also the most problematic type
of client to secure because it's not the
spa it's not oh oh of it's not the token
it's the browser that's the problem
right so there are a couple of attacks
that only exists in browser based
applications and they are because they
live in a shared execution environment
right you have multiple tabs open
multiple applications multiple trust
worthiness of applications and you know
they all start with cross cross-site
request forgery cross-site scripting
because one application is attacking
another right so you know there were two
fundamental ways to do API
authentication in sparse the old style
was with cookies cookies has the
cross-site request
watery problem the new style was access
tokens and you're basically swapping out
cross-site request forgery with
cross-site scripting so you choose your
poison right interestingly interestingly
the the only o of spec I ever read that
says maybe you don't need to use OAuth
is the a wolf browser-based application
spec right they say you know o of of
maced was made for cross-site scenarios
for third party scenarios but you need
to talk to third party things or to you
know maybe your application doesn't need
that feature maybe your application runs
on a site right and here's your front
end and here's your back end what's the
point of using tokens for that use
cookies right you might have an
authentication system that's totally
fine you might have to call external
api's but if the if 90% of your
architecture looks like this then to be
honest to me tokens look like overkill
asking for them managing them keeping
them alive deleting them storing them
and so on
yeah but cookies just on their own won't
cut it right because cross-site request
forgery so we need some sort of anti
fitori protection here and the good news
is for all the people that knew that
it's a problem but never changed their
applications the browser vendors will
gonna fix you up now okay I'm there's
this new thing called same site cookies
where they by default isolate cookies on
the site okay a site is not an origin an
origin is you know protocol plus DNS
name plus port aside is basically
everything that's under a top-level DNS
registrar name your like API dot
mysite.com an app but my Cybercom they
are the same site cookies will travel
but it won't travel beyond that okay the
old way of doing that was NT for tree
tokens that required extra work extra
you know code to write all of the modern
browsers are switching to the same site
model and actually in two weeks time on
the 4th of February chromate he will end
the free here doesn't mean anything good
well it does but it's also bad the free
means that chrome will change the
behavior in
crow matey and all of the cookies by
default will be same site okay before
chrome 80 you had to opt in to the same
side protection but if you know Google
because hey we are Google they just
changed that behavior they changed the
spec because guess what the guy that
writes the spec works for Google so they
will now treat every cookie by default
with same site protection and you can
only imagine how many applications will
break on the 5th of February yeah
they're even more nasty thing is that
only chrome is doing it like this the
others don't yet okay so yeah the next
you know if you are building web
applications the next nine months will
be a mess but it's for the greater good
I think okay so ultimately the O of PCP
spec for web applications distinguishes
between these two scenarios you have an
application with a back-end and you have
an application without a back-end and I
just wanted to show you that crate ASCII
art again I couldn't be bothered in
turning that into PowerPoint things but
but basically what they say is if you
have a back-end all of your you know
protocol handling should be done on the
back end you only protect the front-end
back-end connection with a same side
cookie or a t-4 tree cookie and then all
of the token related things are
happening on the server if you have
tokens at all right maybe you don't need
them at all the only reason you had them
is to talk to your own back-end and that
might be overkill
um the other scenario they call
JavaScript applications without a
back-end so apparently and I never had
that use case but apparently there are
applications which are completely
deployed on CD ends with no back end
whatsoever basically you just download
the JavaScript and they should they
should work then you don't have the
luxury of a back-end which means you the
only thing you can do really is do the
token stuff on the front end okay to be
honest this distinction doesn't make too
much sense to me they should really call
it do you wanna store tokens in the
browser or not right because that's the
question you have to ask yourself do you
want to store them in the browser
then you use this approach do you want
to store them on the server because you
think that's better then use this
approach right they all have their pros
and cons none of them will save you from
cross-site scripting by the way but
that's a different story ma'am but the
real question you have to ask yourself
is how do I store these tokens yeah and
as you know whatever you use to store
your token it's not secure in JavaScript
because it's available by JavaScript and
if somebody injects JavaScript in your
app they can access your data right so
yeah to CSP as good as you can I know
it's not straightforward but try it and
not just say let's turn it on oh it
breaks let's turn it off again next time
that's the wrong approach
okay ah refresh tokens in browsers right
that's another really interesting topic
now now that the browser world is
switching to code flow with pixie
refresh tokens are allowed should we use
them refresh tokens have nice properties
right they are they a long lift and they
they can be used to get new access
tokens which make them really nice for
attack us yeah so you know think think
carefully if you want to store refresh
tokens in the browser yeah if you do
there are a couple of things you can do
like a refresh token rotation sliding
exploration replay detection and so on
so forth to make them more secure I just
wrote a blog post about that actually on
the way here at the airport or don't do
Refresh tokens at all in the sense of
that you are actually binding your
renewal semantics to the session that
you have with the server and once the
user locks out the token cannot be
renewed okay use short token lifetimes
as well that's not a really good advice
here okay
what's next so it turns out if you
follow all of that advice there was
still attack scenarios here okay so you
know o of it's moving into spaces where
we didn't see that coming eight years
ago like financial industry health care
and so on yeah and of course the more
money is involved the more motivated
attack us get to find loopholes in your
system right and
that's a very very good academic paper
that shows more attacks that I haven't
covered here that are not even in the or
Wharf BC piece yeah for example there's
an attack against pixie Wow
but that kind of like that the summary
of all of this is we are pretty good
these days if you follow the advice
there is one weak link and that is still
the browser okay as I said the browser
is very powerful it can show you I it
can follow redirects here but the prose
is also very vulnerable because hey it
shows you I it follows redirects so if
you look at all of the specs that are
currently in the pipeline they all try
to fix one thing the initial
authorization request right where you
send the parameters over the browser to
the server because when somebody can
tamper with them they can do things that
you might not expect can be done okay so
he actually did the way we will go is be
get rid of the authorization request the
way we know it today and the very and
you guess what all of that together this
is being worked on now
oh well free okay and the idea is to get
you to compile all the problems and turn
it into a new base spec that has all of
these things covered but as you know the
IETF it's not like the fastest
organization in the world it will take
many years so people are actually
working today on a thing called a Worf
2.1 right and oh of 2.1 is basically you
apply or if you apply the PCPs and what
you get in the end that will be the new
baseline okay no more implicit no more
password use pixie all the things I just
told you okay that will be you know it's
not official yet but I think that that's
what's going to happen yeah two of the
really interesting ingredients in 2.1 is
one is called secured authorization
requests right I just said this is the
weakest link we have identified it's in
it's happening in the browser if
somebody can tamper with them we can
play tricks on someone yeah so what if
we could remove them altogether
what if we could remove or replace all
of these parameters with this what's
that
it's a JSON web token right that is you
know contains basically all contains all
the parameters as if they would be on
the query string but they are signed and
you can't change them okay and guess
what they have a type yeah that is an
interesting idea but practically
speaking the the UDC urls get very very
long depending on how much you put in
this JSON web tokens yeah so one step
further is this it's called pushed
authorization requests and the idea is
instead of doing an initial
authorization request you first open a
back-channel to the server then you push
all of your parameters on that back
channel to the server
no prowess is involved so far okay this
call is authenticated with the client ID
and the client secret and you can make
that as strong as you want okay
so we're pushing these things first on a
back-channel what this will give us back
is basically an identifier for the
pushed parameters okay and then you are
opening the browser and all you put on
your offers request is the identifier
okay so now on the server side we will
basically reach into our data store we
will get we will resolve the identifier
to the parameters that have been pushed
before by you know authenticated pushed
and then we will do the authorized
request okay and that's all being done
as I said to get rid of these
unverifiable parameters on the front
Channel
I think with that it's pretty cool III
can't wait to implement them okay so
summary you might think now why would I
bought up if at all it seems to be
completely insecure right I mean so many
things are going this and that and I
have to do this and if I forget this and
I'm this happening um I guess the answer
is it's hard it's a hard problem to
solve right Oh of to Oh was the first
iteration of that protocol we learned
and I'm not saying it's insecure I'm
just saying you can do better right and
I'm also saying that still the most
problems we see our implementation flaws
and not protocol flaws yeah you know the
thing is this there are some things you
can't mitigate as a developer there are
some things that are easy to mitigate
right and some things will always stay
hard regardless how hard and the
protocols are if somebody does a
targeted attack against your system it
will always be hard because they analyze
your exact implementation and not just
the general thing right um still you
know people ask me should I use a wharf
at all or should I do my own protocol
and you know the answer is very easy
don't okay what what what a
specification really is it's a
pre-vetted threat model many smart
people have worked on creating the spec
many smart people have tried to break
that spec and many smart people are
still iterating on it and we're getting
improvements if you write your own
protocol there's exactly only one smart
person that wrote it worked on it
there's also exactly only one smart
person to try to break it right so
what's better right so yes I think Olaf
is here to stay and it will improve and
it will get better but we are pretty
good thank you
[Applause]